[Musique]
allez on clôture ce journal avec vous
mais l'ani poquet bonsoir on ça le 20
mars c'est le printemps mais à saint
quentin en yvelines il a pris un peu
d'avancé grâce à la poésie le cet
événement est au coeur de votre couture
culture oui et je vous donne un petit
coup de programme qui va arriver très
très vite parce que le printemps de la
poésie il commence dès ce mercredi 13
mars avec un atelier à la médiathèque du
canal il gaudin bien connu des saint
quentinois puisqu'il s'est occupé
d'insurrection poétique ce qu'on voit à
l'image mais demain et proposera avec
olivier journaux des lectures des jeux
d'écriture et de la musique et pour
cette 21e édition le thème c'est la
beauté c'est le thème national qui a été
décidée jacques fournet le directeur des
exilés politiques nous en dit un mot sur
la déclinaison saint-quentinoise très
personnel
la beauté est alors que faire de ça et
donc on l'a décliné mais en même temps
c'est un thème qui n'en est pas un on se
moque un peu
on emprunte tous les chemins qu'on peut
emprunter qu'on veut emprunter sur ce
territoire pour faire en sorte que la
poésie qu'elle évoque ou non la beauté
soit présenté au public
alors pendant ce printemps il y aura des
bals des expositions mais aussi des
rendez vous plus étonnant les poètes
vont vous inviter à faire des marches
comme celles au départ de magny les
hameaux ce samedi 7 mars mais aussi une
sieste vous avez bien entendu grégory en
deux comme en 2018 les artistes vont se
succéder durant trois heures en mêlant
note
emoze en douceur avec un idéal toucher
le plus grand nombre de personnes
écoutez on essaye on essaye de faire en
sorte que tout le monde se sente un jour
ou l'autre concernés par la poésie
moi c'est mon cheval de bataille depuis
depuis quelques décennies quand même
maintenant et je suis moi persuadé qu'on
a tous quelque chose à voir avec la
poésie à un moment ou à un autre de
notre vie même si le but n'est pas
d'attirer des centaines de milliers de
personnes à venir écouter un poète
devant son micro
l art il y aura aussi une grande
première les 30 et 31 mars prochain il y
aura le vit
l'âge des mots à la commanderie des
performances dansées des causeries sur
le langage et une dictée vous pouvez
commencer à réviser
merci mélanie on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants la présentation de
votre émission le 7-8 culture